[Music]
i
love this story
did a winning quarterback fumble by
ignoring a chick who took a tumble yet
the athlete showed no reaction to the
woman who ended up in traction
and now this qb's most famous pass
was leaving a woman who fell on her ass
so we should win emmys for that social
media is calling out rams qb matt
stafford for doing nothing as a female
sports photographer fell backwards off a
stage
right in front of his own two eyes yeah
to be fair he is a passer not a receiver
it happened during the rams super bowl
victory celebration had no idea they won
but we haven't seen a blonde face plant
like that since cat at three for one
margarita night
apparently the photographer ironically
named kelly smiley
was getting ready to take a picture of
stafford and his wife
or soon to be ex-wife when she lost her
footing and fell off stage literally the
guy did nothing but take a swig of water
oh i need to be hydrated
and leave his wife to deal with the mess
to be fair he was still up on a high
stage and people down below were
attending to her meanwhile smiley posted
a video on instagram wearing a back
brace and thanking everyone for reaching
out
a friend of her set up a gofundme page
to help get smiley back on her feet
faster as long as she doesn't donate to
peaceful protesters of course as for
stafford
who watched smiley go down
after some outcry he's now stepping up
he and the rams issued a joint statement
saying they're covering all of her
hospital bills and replacing her cameras
well good on him i say because if anyone
knows what it's like to hit bottom it's
a quarterback who played 12 years in
detroit
little football joke tyrus
there's this there's a thing when
somebody does something and you can't
look at it in the same way and i think
of the seinfeld episode right george
because stanza runs out during the fire
yeah it's like a children's birthday he
ran over the children he pushed
everybody out of the way yes he saved
himself yes
unfortunately matt did not save himself
uh he's
i i know what he did you know when she
fell he didn't think it was that big a
deal he turned his head because he
probably was going to laugh and drink
water like and thought he was being
funny and clever yeah unfortunately his
wife is a saint yeah and so that even
makes the optics is even worse as he
walks away drinking the bottle of water
makes him look smug exactly yeah and
then the worst thing happens
she got really hurt yeah because if she
would have gone up and everybody was
laughing it would have been fine yeah
but you know and then a joint statement
which means he got a call from the gm
going you better you better save this
yeah because you can kiss goodbye the
endorsement deals those are gone and
people are going to look at you
differently and it's just a it's a bad
bad look on his character i hate it
because i can't
i went to school in nebraska and when
people fell on the ice i would always
turn my head like
like laughing because for whatever
reason
people falling makes me laugh i can't
control it i don't want it to happen yes
but yeah and i never asked to pick him
up because i'm laughing at him you know
i think he's going to lose the all-state
you know uh endorsement you know you're
in good hands oh that disney commercial
is going to get cut too yeah i you know
um the one thing that drives me crazy i
just got to say this no you don't need a
bottle of water everywhere you're not
like
going across the sahara desert right
you're an adult there's a water fountain
we have water fountains in this building
our produ our floor director just used
it during the show
anyway what i'm saying is without
permission without permission people you
don't need to have water all the time
the woman falls and he goes oh better
hydrate a lot
first of all oh i'm sorry it was hot
it's california that's very obtuse of
you yes because he wants to hydrate yeah
hydration that's probably the best thing
he did in that situation i like how his
complete lack of character turned into a
rant against water like what did water
had water
i didn't really think this was that bad
until i actually watched it over again
and now i'm just like holy you know
you've ever heard that saying character
is what is the character is who you are
when you think nobody's watching right
right and so he didn't really think that
there were cameras on him and that is
who he really is and you know it it
sucks it's despicable but you know at
least she's not severely injured at
least her hospital bills are going to be
taken care of at least she'll get more
work out of this and she's got the
gofundme with i think it was like 45
000. yeah that's the last time i checked
yeah unless it gets frozen it's so it
looks like somebody pushed a button for
a trapdoor every time i look at it like
i'm looking around like who has the
little button because i was when i was a
kid susan i always wanted a trap door
just to watch people fall in it i don't
know why but i had some therapy after
that and i found out because
i was kept in a small basement for most
of my childhood life and so i wanted to
pay that back to complete strangers what
about endorsements susan it's okay let's
not discuss what i just said
focus on the endorsements you're the
business lady that was pretty um that
was a great choice yes a lot of
confessing happening parents
okay you know leaving a capable hands of
a woman that was probably more sober
than her husband so let kelly handle it
emergency situation oh so he's saying
you take care of this you're sober i'm
wasted ooh that's a good excuse cat did
we kat what are your thoughts on this i
can't wait to hear
[Laughter]
i think that he should have said he was
wasted yeah i think he should have said
he was wasted
because that makes sense and uh then he
it's good that he paid for the whole
thing because he made a mistake and
sometimes you make mistakes should he be
branded forever with this mistake hey
look it's the guy it's like when the nfl
starts it's the chance so it's like no
because it's a mistake that like shows
you didn't care about people not like a
mistake for example if your co-host had
for example maybe accidentally deleted
your entire monologue today at 4 45 p.m
and just told you now but we got it back
did you delete my model no i think
somebody called his name maybe someone
called this wait a minute water there's
water somewhere there's water i did
water i pressed the wrong button my
heart dropped to my ass and i thought
about fleeing the building and i drank
water and walked away
it's a very confessional episode tonight
how did they get it how do they get it
back i don't know a lot of hard work and
so i'm gonna buy everybody pizza oh they
had to go get i.t that was that's right
i'm buying everybody pizza just like he
paid for the go fund me
awesome well i'm glad that
boy that would have been a bad scene for
you
i i thought i thought about scathing i
was like i have to start a new life yes
she was gonna come back down to florida
with me she was just gonna like leave it
all like i'm new to identity
all right we gotta move on hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else